foreign
good morning everyone and welcome to the
September meeting of wastenet
um we have a fairly full agenda today
but just by way of starting off
um we have a an additional face around
the table this morning uh Neville
Phillips if you'd like to introduce
yourself Neville and um been or give it
some context following
uh thank you Mr Jim for those who don't
know me uh on Neville Phillips councilor
award councilor from Matera District
councilor for GDC of third term uh prior
to that I was on the material community
board since 2003.
I'm looking forward to being part of
this wastenet group
part of my job when I worked currently
for the GDC was at the transfer station
in Gore itself so I have a an avid
interest in waste in the district so um
look forward to the challenge
thank you chairman and thanks for that
counselor um so just to put some context
to it
um I will be stepping off the waste net
committee over the next few meetings I
will be away actually for the next one
and then probably after that
um obviously if you can wait just so I
can free up some more of my time I'm
Gonna Leave You In The Trusted hands of
both councilor hovel and councilor
Phillips
[Music]
yeah but hopefully get this three bin
system over the line first
and I also welcome the visitors that
we've got today uh Dan Butterfield and
Pam is it
um I didn't write it
sorry
Dallas
Stella Stella thank you
who will be giving us a a presentation
shortly
do we have any apologies and no everyone
is is present this due here today we
have a late agenda item
and uh
this deals with Bond Contracting
um
it's progressing to wasteco New Zealand
limited the reason why the item was not
on the agenda is that staff were not in
their position to provide advice to this
group prior
to the agenda being compiled because of
contract negotiation the paper cannot
wait until a further meeting because of
the sale of bond Contracting on the 30th
of September
I moved at the waste Advisory Group
consider the late item sale of bond
Contracting to wasteco Limited
do I have a second to please
yeah so Rob Scott
um all those in favor please say aye
against no carried and that will be
dealt with in the public excluded
portion
um for reasons set out later
do we have any Declarations of conflicts
of interest
appear to be none
confirmation of the minute to Tom page
one of the agenda
makes the public excluded can I just
borrow it for a moment please right so
are there any errors or omissions that
people have noted in the minutes please
um
there was one issue in relation to
the
pelletization
and I can't see that on on this copy
here
no it comes up in the public executive
part of the minute so if there's no
comments Corrections can I have a move
the minute to be accepted
in
and um
seconded
Barry Stewart thank you all those in
favor say aye
against
carried
next item on the agenda is
kawakai and so this is a background
paper on green waste and food waste
minimization pilot for Southland
so if Dan and Stella come forward to the
table
I'm looking forward to your presentation
here today and there is a microphone
yeah so I just asked you if you just
push the button on the red light will
show up
um
thank you for having us here today my
name is Stella O'Connor and I'm here
today representing the middle hecka Kai
Collective
um and I have with me Dan Butterfield
from kiwi skips unfortunately Janice Lee
from kuha Kai couldn't be here today
she's had to rush to Australia as her
father is very ill
so you haven't got the A Team you have
the B team
and we got some very hurried messages
from Janice last night about today's
presentation so we'll do our best
um so I think you've received a proposal
from Janice regarding a community-led
composting initiative
um and she has been in contact with the
waste
Ministry of environment
and has been approved to apply for the
minimization fund
um they are also looking or talking to
her about whether she has the regional
councils involved in this project or or
know about the project as well so hence
the reason coming here today to ensure
that it aligns with what you're doing at
Council
um
and with that we have also checked that
on the Southland Waste Management
minimization plan
2020-2026 the proposed initiative does
really align with the regional strategic
direction of waste as a resource
and that report
it highlights that there is a high
volume of organic waste going to
landfill
um and that you want to take action
regarding that high volume of waste
going to landfill
you've got various
strategies in your plan around what
their action is and we note that one of
the actions is to partner with industry
and Community to support Community
community-led programs
and so we're just here today to offer
that opportunity to come on board with
the community-led project
um so I'm not really part of the
composting initiative but as I mentioned
I'm part of America Kai Collective and
we have presented to all councils in
environment Southland recently regarding
the
um
good food roadmap that we're bringing
together which is really the insights
from Community around how to strengthen
our local food system to improve food
security food sovereignty and food
resilience and so one of the priorities
that we are hearing from our communities
is we want to see an increase in
community-led initiatives like
composting
but I'll hand it over to Dan and he can
carry on with the more technical stuff
yeah perfect good everyone my name is
Dan Butterfield my
um background is in waste I've started
kiwi skips almost six years ago
um we've grown quite a big uh following
cross invercargill and Southland and in
invercargill we have an organic waste
collection wheelie bin curbside service
which is has proven to be really really
successful but uh we believe a lot of
their organic waste we're collecting
is going to landfill
as a capping at the in the ICC
which is what we want to try divert that
and put that through a composting system
um so over the
what over the past couple years I've
been really digging deep into the
composting systems and I've been joined
a few composting groups across New
Zealand and I keep finding the most
best way for Processing organic waste is
where the hot rot and vessel composting
system so that's why we're proposing
that system for the waste
um in invisal composting systems offer
several advantages composting is can
number one composting is contained
within the vessel allowing us for a
better environmental and human impact
control
in this organic waste can be processed
with proper care
um
opportunities for strict monitoring and
Reporting we can get from this invisal
system
um also rapid and sustainable heating
due to Thermal properties within the
vessel
controlled air delivery and scalp
scalability because we want to use this
five ton per day system as a pilot to
work our way up to handling the entire
regions organic waste
invisal Solutions do require a
significant initial investment as you've
seen in the has everyone received the
let's see
perfect which outlines the investment
and what it looks like
um
the this offers extensive control and
com containment capabilities rendering
them's ideal for small to medium-sized
installations
the proposal for the modular system like
the one we're suggesting would be a
perfect fit for Southland allowing the
establishment of multiple satellite
plants to serve entire town populations
across Southland this approach would
minimize Transportation costs and
improve local sustainability
the hot rod system prevents a Cutting
Edge generation of invisal composting
Solutions designed to overcome
traditional limitations
what's even more impressive is that
these systems are designed and
manufactured right here in New Zealand
however it's unfortunate that the
company Behind These remarkable
Innovations is finding greater success
overseas and more forward-thinking
countries New Zealand's often reactive
rather than proactive nature coupled
with the tendency of lag behind the
times
might cause us to miss this opportunity
right on our doorstep so we basically
want to grab this plant and um
yeah hook into it and get it going and
try divert a lot of organic waste
yeah
foreign
thank you um do we have any questions
well
yeah thank you and thank you for the
presentation um just looking at the
capacity of it we're in in that handout
You've Got 5 000 tons daily so is that
the size of the one that you're looking
at
kgs Okay cool so five five tab so Watson
page 11 and the green
um
cell referred to five thousand tons
so that's where our confusion had come
from back to you rob yeah
um but yeah just just around say the
for the for the scale the volume of
stuff going through you you need
probably quite quite a volume to
yeah like does it need that kind of
volume to operate effectively I guess is
what I'm asking yeah absolutely and
Kiwis gets alone we are collecting five
ton per day at the moment
um well joint with kohakai and the food
waste collections
so from a Southland District point of
view to actually
transport the organic material from
South and have you got any sort of
options around how that would work
around the whole
whole area
would they be with the collections or
yeah yeah so
um just through wheelie bin services
collection Services as well as
um we through Genesis connections we're
targeting the schools
and um restaurants
because at the moment like I'm speaking
mainly about the greenway sort of things
it's going to transfer stations and some
of them are sort of community sort of
run ones but we're
um we're having to pay that waste
minimization media on it so if there was
an alternative solution there that would
be um quite quite useful
yeah
yeah so currently all this waste is
going to Bond Street Transfer Station
from there is shredded and I'm sure
someone else in this room will have
better understanding but it's not
actually leaving that site it's used as
capping on the old landfill there
so so if if we had say just
hypothetically speaking here sort of
half a dozen or so
sort of points around Southland District
would would there be an appetite to
potentially pick up larger bins from
from those areas rather than individual
households
yeah well if we had these plants like
one and Gore one in Winton you know
there we would try to process that there
and keep it locally and distribute it to
that local community because this is
going to be a beautiful Rich compost
yeah but this this here is the pilot
that we're talking so yeah looking at
replicating this around absolutely yes
cool thank you
further questions Ian
um so Janice has been talking to the
ministry of environment and they've
approved her to apply so that means that
it must fit their criteria if they've
approved her to apply
for
to MFE yeah
um so but they may not fund the whole
project
if you didn't appreciate
yes that's enough to feed the pilot oh
yes yes really you don't wanna
like in my neighborhood I know myself
you know and
Engineers are and
and people are right into growing their
own veggies
across out of there quite reluctant to
to
now listen to Robert can you turn your
mic on please
okay
for radio
um
so
um what about the community aspect of
getting behind educating people and I've
looked online you can buy you know
Standalone home composting systems quite
economical wouldn't that make sense I
mean as well as yours obviously you've
got people they pay for it then they get
rid of it that's great but then there's
the other people who who are quite Keen
to grow their own vegetables and and do
everything like that
I think that's fantastic but we need to
start a conversation
don't we and this perhaps this project
does start a com conversation about
diverting food from waste so currently
40 to 50 of the waste and but in
people's bin is going to landfill at the
moment so it's fantastic that there are
communities like your community that are
actually composting yeah well I'd say
you know I've got zero food going to my
Arena yeah and so have I because I have
a bokashi system and I have a garden but
um your stats alone and um I think more
people here could probably tell you how
much of the city's
waste is actually food as well
yeah if there was if every household had
their own composting system there would
be no need for us to be here today
having this conversation but that is not
the case we and we try to educate in two
communities to get their own composting
systems going in on
um the part of compost ingredients
across Southland
and it's a really really hard one to
take off
yeah well we've we had presentation or
on-screen meeting with a couple of guys
from the MEP
and the signaling that the government
are looking for a compulsory
building system or diversion of green
waste now I mean that that's going to
meet with opposition because of the fact
that a lot of people that were known
invercargill don't don't put green waste
in their red bin so the interesting
actually those figures you've given me
Stella
um when was this latest swap test done
when when do we when did we last do an
analysis of laying out all the waste on
the ground and measuring what actually
composes our ways to landfill when was
that done how recent is that
these figures you're talking about
I just was looking at your Waste
Management
wasted whips
annual report and also we've done uh
We've looked into schools as well and
seen how much their wavy bins have
um fourways so for example Aurora
College when we
checked their waste spins as well
um before we help them with the
composting system
um and because some of these schools
areko which is
food lunches and schools as well so
there's actually a considerable amount
of food waste going into bins okay so
the schools could be treated separately
I guess we you know being a counselor we
look after we don't come after schools
no no but it all ends up in your
Souls
yeah yeah but it's used for land
recovery you know without well then the
other question is Anya
on the uh
pamphlet here underneath underneath the
section it's got in quotation marks we
will avoid many trucks traveling what
what does that mean can you explain that
sentence
I'm just trying to
understand that
just Justin here I think this is um so I
I'm just going to say I've just seen
this this morning myself and Janice has
created this one pager so it's just
easier for everyone to read but what
what she's talking about here is
localized
um
what food waste diversions so scene food
waste being composted in local areas and
yes by 2030 all your councils have an
obligation to have some sort of food
curbside
um collection and so here's an
opportunity to actually get some data
before then around
um you know what could work start
changing the mindsets of our community
around what they're putting in their
bins and starting their own composting
at home but no one would travel 260k to
drop off GreenWise that's insane it just
says that that's happening
I wish
anyway if I can help reading one of the
other reports
um the rubbish trucks from Southland I
think it's about a 400k round trip if
they do the whole lot so if you're
thinking of taking Greenways from places
like um Tiana Leon stopping somewhere
else on the way to invercargill you
could quite easily end up with oh yeah
just that with when you said 2030 is the
government's going to make this happen
look I remember in 2012 when we said we
had mfp come to us and talk about
product stewardship
product stewardship was about you know
manufacturers and the retailers owning
the product and having responsibility
you know to divert it at the end well
we're now 200 2023
okay that was 11 years ago so sorry I'm
the MEP
I have no credibility with me sorry
right yeah Christine you had a question
my question is just in relation to
um what's the minimum talents you need
to operate daily and that relates back
to the waste that's coming from the
school
um lunches whatever it may be because
they may well stop in the future I mean
treasure we are considering that now but
also one would think they'll be
addressing the issue of wastage around
those meals at the beginning so if that
occurs then offers coming through to you
does that make any difference to the
efficiency and operation of the plant
yeah
um well there's sadly we're coming
across no shortage of organic waste and
going to landfill so we're pulling that
out five ton per day is what the
machine's capable of but there is no
minimum we can just keep feeding this
vessel and um yeah and within 10 days
that beautiful Ridge compost is coming
out the other end
cool wall
probably
off in the case of Gore it probably
wouldn't generate the 5 000 or kilograms
five tonne
um a day but you're saying it doesn't
matter
um the plant that you're getting is a
second hand one at six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars if there are satellite
ones built later then you're looking at
a million plus per unit
yes that's that's correct
are there any other questions
just on that last I mean just reflecting
on there if you're looking to putting
one in Winterton for arguments that I
just struggle to see with the
the volume and the cost of investment
whether that would be worthwhile as
opposed to transporting
the
compost well the green waste to turn
here we're just looking at um
reflecting on piano
Winston
um even sort of up at Ethel where
there's a current Greenway site just
thinking about how it actually
logistically shift all of it yourself
rather than having those those plants
but um because it looks like that's the
only size there's not smaller versions
of it is
foreign
thank you in in the papers it refers to
the need to get some
um resource consents and the like
how long do you anticipate that's going
to take all right let's cancel all this
I don't know
um resource concerns could take
like
um all right so you've got an unknown
time process to go through plus the
application to MFE
um asking for funding
um so I guess for the purpose of today
you're giving us a bit of a briefing on
the project
and at some time in the future you might
come out back with your hands out saying
we need some more money please is that a
fear summary
is that um so yeah we'll
this is this is really
I don't think that's so much the case
we've got a really good outline and
we've been quite
um
generous on what we're what we're we're
putting the application here
um
I have got a
environmental company who has done a lot
of groundwork on the um
conscience
I would say geez I I didn't want to
throw anything I'll put down eight
thousand dollars for the resource
consent and three months
but I just don't know how but that's all
built into the
what we're asking for
and probably something we haven't
mentioned Janice has been working with
coin South on
um this is a business proposal as well
just to make sure that um she's got
everything going right there
is part of your application between
Murphy
do you need or is it desirable to have
something from waste Nick to present to
them yes Council backing
right
pristine
so just to clarify this application
today is not requesting any funding at
the local level it's requesting support
from waste net to for the other
application through two yeah that's
right support
um and we are asking MEP for 100 which
has they have granted in the past they
have told us but if not then yeah we
probably will come back
asking for some funding I think
yeah I'll be very interested to know how
much of the restaurants are in this
total because
yeah
a lot of this total will be restaurants
burner totally and I've done a lot of
work with restaurants to try
um
minimize what they're doing based Wise
by separating cardboard food waste just
as as they've been through such tough
time it's a service offers are going and
basically audit and try help
reduce their waste and that's how we've
sort of come up with the figures of the
organic waste we can call from them
sources yep
any other questions
we have a motion that's in the report
that the uh that the report be received
uh there are any um people around the
table who want to phrase a more active
resolution
Rob
I mean I'd say maybe happy to find out
support behind this pilot going through
the MEP so if we wanted to add that into
the motion I'd certainly support them
so that would result in in a resolution
that the report be received and that the
waste net Advisory Group endorsed The
Proposal being presented to Ministry for
the environment as that along the lines
of what you're about to move
thank you do we have a second for that
motion Barry
any discussion arising
appears to be none I'll put the motion
then all those in favor say aye
against
carried
so thank you for your presentation here
today Dan and Stella the outcome will be
a letter going from us
possibly to directly to MFA with a copy
to you
endorsing the proposal for funding from
MFE
thank you very much
item five
the wasting it waste of landfill
performance update which is a page 22 of
the agenda
this is being prepared by Council staff
and are there any questions arising in
relation to that report please
do the staff have anything further to
add to the report
that hasn't been circulated none Ian
the first graph
where it shows
monthly waste the landfill has the
comment under the first bullet point
that it's 13.8 below last year
but it doesn't
the red line which is
a sort of current
doesn't
well we're just talking the blue dot
here I'm trying to work yeah the Blue
Dart is part of the 23-24 year right the
red line is the previous year ending
June okay which is quite abysmal
compared to the previous five-year
average
the red Line's quite a bit above the
dotted line yes last year is above the
dust line but the blue line for this
year for July is below the long term
average so what is that what is our
Benchmark now I remember back at the
start of
2010 when wasting it started it was 650
kilograms
um a person or something like that what
is it now what is our our waste
diversion Target what is it uh can staff
help us there please
from 2010 2000
we are still following the same
um 650 figure but we can look at um
reconsidering that figure over the next
two years because it's post covered now
and we need to see a trend first to
reconsider that figure
sorry I'd also add that you can just say
those kpi calculations at the end of the
report
there appear to be none we have a
recommendation the report be received
and note the waste to them from
recycling data on Trends and the creasa
Superstar
Etc can I have a mover for the
recommendation please
Ian second
Rob
all those in favor say aye
against carried
item six waste net education Community
activity updates commencing at page 30.
so this is an update on education
community activities prepared by the
invercargill city council
do the staff have anything additional to
add to what's in the report
now are there any questions arising
Ian
um recycling of green waste
since we had the topic before has this
been actively
sort of promoted in the schools
to have their own composting systems
because obviously they've I know a lot
of schools have their own veggie gardens
and stuff
um so obviously it would make sense is
this something that we're that we're
doing
stuff
at the moment the program is around
education in schools around what they do
in their homes primarily at the moment
we don't have a program where we're
proactively working with schools around
their green waste diversion
opportunity
is that something we should be doing
[Music]
what do you think
microphone yeah I would love to see it
obviously after the previous
conversation with kiwi skips about
I thought it'd be quite an obvious one
wouldn't it
well I guess
um pose from your question as a
statement you would like to see the
education and the schools expanded to
uncover other issues
well yeah yeah I just thought
um so is that something once we have a
manager in place
that further thought can be given to
yeah well if you're grown
vegetables at school you know and that
gets the whole the kids are doing it and
obviously if you're growing vegetables
or flowers you need compost
and what better source of compost would
be from your own schools quite large
green waste
yeah so I don't know maybe it's too
obvious I don't know
sorry something's bringing on my um
wrist
um
hopefully it's not
so I think I've
um summarized that uh conversation to
that that's something that we would hope
the staff would take into account with
future programs
I think there'd be two pieces that I'd
respond to with that
um we have got in place a essentially an
education plan which is the plan that we
set in place for this financial year
which was what was approved by wastenet
and which is the plan that we are
currently working to this year
um you'd also recall that part of our
program is around a business case on
Organics which I'd expect that once
we've started to work through that
Organics business case process we'll
start to see a clearer direction of
where we should be going in terms of
that education component and whether or
not our best
um you know investment is better aimed
at residential is better aimed at
schools is better aimed at business just
needing to get a little bit further
through that process to decide where our
best opportunities are
thank you Aaron
um so
um you're right and from that really
something's highlighted and no doubt
you'll have regard to it on programming
your future work are there any other
questions arising um from the item thank
you Rob
thanks guys you're just a comment around
I know the last sort of contaminated
recycling in our area came from there
was a stronger digit in otatio and
ramsden
is it worth sort of connecting that
education aspect where some of those
eras are occurring and the rabbits to
try and Target it from that direction as
well
just noting that those schools that are
on that list
and sort of tying up with whether
the issues appear to be coming from in
case you're wanting to set the
priorities a little bit
or just if there is an issue in a
particular area targeting the education
into that area I think would be would be
useful yeah Aaron's nodding her head so
I take that as something that I have
regard to an Era if you want yeah we'll
absolutely have regard to that and check
that whether I'm just not sure whether
we've had that on our radar but I'll
have a look at that but the other piece
is also around trying to make sure that
we hit as many schools as we possibly
can and obviously get that share of
schools across the three different
councils as well
thank you any other questions
so we have a recommendation the report
being received can I have a remover for
that please
Ian seconder
um
Christine thank you
moving on to item seven
oh those in favor
say aye
against carried
thank you item seven waste minimization
Community grants and update starting at
page 42 of the agenda so it's just
setting out a process there with a
opening on the 18th of September closing
on the 30th of October with fifty
thousand dollars being available I guess
on a contestable fund are there any
questions arising from the report please
Ian
per annum is that what we always do is
it 50 per annum or is this just this one
off 50 for this year
um do we have a and and do we carry
forward stuff if we don't
use the 50 Grand or what do we do I I
just want to know what our policy is
with this funding press Erin can you
help us out please
yes so for some years wastenet has had
an allocation of money for to support
Community projects uh what it's not had
in the past though is a formalized
process for doing that which means that
Community groups weren't necessarily
aware that the fund existed and we were
finding that we we weren't expending the
money each year
this is the first year that we've
formalized this into an annual process
where we've sort of gone out proactively
we've started with fifty thousand
dollars as being slightly more than what
we've historically spent but certainly
not as much as some other councils are
putting forward in their Community
grants process as I recall I think
Queenstown Lakes spends about 150 000 on
their Community grants process per annum
so this was essentially a an opportunity
for us to trial whether a more
formalized process got the word out
better we expect that it probably will
and that will probably
um exhaust that fifty thousand dollars
pretty quickly it will then be an option
as to whether or not we look to expand
that program in future years
so this is the fund a school could apply
for money to have their own composting
system absolutely cool
given that
waste net is operated as a a profit in
the last 12 months we have the ability
to use some of that if we wish
for actually increasing it above the
fifty thousand dollars
um but we would need to consider that on
a Case by case basis any other questions
Rob
yeah I just figured that I had a very
similar question but just checking that
there will be an appetite if it is over
subscribed to actually look at it at the
time rather than maybe waiting another
year because if you do have a whole lot
of suitable projects and we've got money
sort of sitting there especially and
given that there hasn't been much
activity in this area in the past it'll
be good to to have that discussion at
the time
Christine
um thank you
to terms of the darty have available for
the
for them is that able to be broken down
into communities I mean Rob just
mentioned before about a TaoTao
community so that they understand what
the issues might be in their community
and then can relate
projects directly to those issues that
are presenting in the different
communities
we haven't put out a I guess a
comprehensive analysis Beyond obviously
our wmmp and swap analysis to community
groups as to where we're seeing I guess
different hot spots of issues
possibly something we could look at
doing in the future what what this
program is more around is that
empowering the community to be able to
come up with their own ideas and their
own Concepts and if that's aligned to
what we have in place in as our
objectives under the wmmp
empowering them to be able to get on and
do that
what we'd be looking at as part of the
criteria though is which projects have
come forward and which ones align most
strongly to our problem areas and those
criteria which is where they'd be
prioritized for funding ahead of other
areas
thank you I I just would think that with
our community board structure that we
have in place that that analysis will be
very useful for them encouraging local
projects at a community lead as well
okay
the recommendation
suggests the the chair and two other
waste net staff so that would class the
chair as a staff member I think maybe
um
the thought is possibly the cheer and a
staff member from each Council
so that there's full integration in
terms of
the way that it's looked at any any
comment on that please
around the table
we've got a nodding of of people right
in in any other discussion questions on
the issue please
just a quick clarification I was just
talking to Jason between the last minute
and this one that Community boards might
be able to apply to this from
themselves it's just not that clear in
this report but I believe that they may
be able to Erin
the only comment I'd just add around the
staff representation would be giving the
opportunity to date when we had
discussed who would who would be on that
evaluation committee there hadn't been a
lot of interest in having a staff rep
from every Council so it's one that we
can provide the opportunity but we
wouldn't hold up the process otherwise
thank you
so we have three motions oh sorry three
recommendations and the report that have
been received and got a question coming
from Ben sorry chair um just on that
point would we within if the staff
member isn't interested then offer it to
the
council's uh wear group presentation
whether they would be interested and if
neither are then
would that work as well
um we could possibly word it then that
it would be the chair and one
representative of each Council
and it leaves it open as to whether they
were elected or a staff member or
yeah Aaron
what I'd be I'd be Keen to
caution is that we don't wind up in a
little bit of a tug of war around
funding priorities I guess what I'd say
is the advantage to the waste net staff
is that the wastenet staff are the ones
who are meant to be looking at this on a
regional basis the role of the waste net
Advisory Group is to advocate for your
individual
circumstance so I guess I'd just be a
little bit concerned around we want to
make sure that this is a process that we
can move through quickly and efficiently
what is the best process to to do that
moving forward
and Evil
I think just to uh letting the people
know that that
air Heritage
um I'm part of the Heritage group in in
the regional one
is that we rely basically uh quite
substantially on on the staff to give us
recommendations on on
funding so yeah I think the group going
forward if they rely on this staff here
I think it works very well
so we're in just on that third
recommendation
um the the group of
um the the chair and up to three staff
um
are you wanting them to have the
delegation to approve the grants
or to report back to this group because
it's not clear from that recommendation
intention would be to approve the grants
and then to report that back to the
committee right
um so the the
um recommendation probably needs to be
reworded then agrees that the panel to
consider and approve the grounds
received
um
and in the makeup and to report back to
wastenet or to The Advisory Group
so can I have a mover for
just wait for
okay
um
agrees to consider and approve the
grants received and include waste
advisory groups here and representative
from each Council
no
and
up to three staff
from each Council no no no no no full
stop
okay
any further discussion yeah Rob just a
question on that in the case of it being
over subscribed would that meant to come
back to waste net or with the staff with
that group have the discretion to
go above the 50k if need be the the
approval that's there at present uh is
only in terms of the item which is the
50k it may well be that leaves open the
option of the group coming back to
um The Advisory Group to say we've got
some worthwhile projects here
consider these as well please or
consider upping the amount
so we've got that motion plus the other
one sort of received the report and
endorse the timeline can I have a mover
for the three please
Ian and second Barry all those in favor
say aye
against
carried
item eight an update on the waste action
plan starting at page 52 of the agenda
are there any
um questions from the floor please
Ian
and uh well thanks Mary uh the fourth
bubble uh curbside standardization right
at the bottom it's got staff developing
then audit template now yeah is
happening bin inspections or what is
that I I put a question mark beside the
same thing
Aaron they have to comment on that
please
so to the point around noting where our
problem areas are uh there is a piece of
work that we had on our work plan for
the year to start doing some Trials of
of exactly that of Bin inspections to
see which areas of the community are
getting it right and which areas are the
of the community are not getting it
quite right to allow us to come up with
how we're going to best Target those
areas going forward
so so uh when I was at the local
government conference
um a couple of months ago in
Christchurch I spoke with the
chair of infrastructure of Christchurch
city council and asked about
um their their contamination of their
recycling bins and they said they did
have a problem but what they did was
they they used
um
bin inspections you know lifting their
lid and having a look as well as
a reward system and they actually put
gold stars
on the actual outside of the beds now
to me that it's not me but anyway what I
did was it created a sense of community
pride and they had a nose without a star
felt a bit left out so obviously they
they improved their actions and they
the percentage drop in contamination was
phenomenal that they achieved
all through this sort of program so I'm
just wondering if it's worth a phone
call
to to Christchurch to
you know like you know readers on the
wheel and they were it was remarkable
that the figures they achieved
and dropping this down yeah
so
a piece of information there any other
questions comments
there is reference
um and under the glass urine to Joint
consultation by the councils
um and in the final quarter of this
Current financial year
while I understand that's what
um
invercargill proposes I'm not certain
that that's the approach been thought
about by the other councils
um I don't know Rob if you want to
commenting with us on you're you're in a
position to indicate
here given the um the cost predicament
for us so that I don't think in the
timing of going out for conservation and
literally what six weeks
um I think for us it would form more of
the long-term plan thing not that we're
not against separating out the glass but
I think from that extra bin curbside
collection it's a bigger conversation
for us and I don't think we'd be quite
ready to go out to that joint joint
conversation we have the chief executive
from Gore with us Steve welcome
um just wondering from the goal point of
view where consultation on the the three
bins is sitting
teams
wondering if you can use a mic so
everyone can hear cheers
I quite like being in that green Beaver
but um yes we're looking at going early
because it's a clear objective of the
gore District Council to introduce a
revised curbside collection system by
one July 2025 to do that we really need
to be doing it consultation towards the
end of this calendar year not the
financial year so the idea being that
it's really a clear direction from the
communities given and we'll just box on
and then load that into our new ltp but
for commencement ones alive Because by
the time you need the lead time to to
order the um the third bin we need to be
out there I think November or so and I
think Sonia's and her team are working
on that basis
thank you
Ian
um look two two things but the first one
I'll carry on with the class and
um
obviously the idea is to stop the
contamination
going into the processing side of
Southern disabilities and the recycling
plant now
if if we don't achieve some consistency
as invercargill being the gatekeeper of
the contract with
the recycling plant we may have to say
that sorry from this point there is no
glass in going in a recycling bin and
that is an offense sorry because if we
can't we've got to take it out because
it's just it's turning to custard there
so we're going to get alignment then
we've got our system in plan to go
through the ltp and we're looking
perhaps the earliest is 2025
but that's something I think everyone
should be aiming for otherwise there
will be no if you are doing yellow bin
there is no glass going into it
is an item and the public excluded
session talking about the glass
recycling but
um for the purpose of the next item on
the agenda given that we have run at a
profit this year and that the issue that
invercargill faces with regard to
contamination is is really a region-wide
issue
that given that we have surplus funds
available that aren't committed whether
there would be some support to actually
get a report from
staff
I guess looking at two things and one
would be to do a trial
in terms of an area of invercargill once
identified
to how we work through those issues of
um doing both vetting
but as part of that
um there's some
the need to undertake some enforcement
action in the event of of continuing
non-compliance
while you describe the stars and and
they may or may not be nervous and that
I don't know I want to get some feedback
but equally if if there are three
um red flags on a particular thing we
would want to be taking some sort of
action
um from the work that Ian has done in
his talks with Christchurch
um they have Provisions in their Waste
Management
plan that enable them to do that and the
other option is to have Provisions in a
bylaw
so I'd be interested to know if there's
support around the table to get a report
for our next meeting
looking at the costs associated and the
cost and benefits as well of either
tweaking our management plan
completely reviewing the management plan
or looking at the option of a regional
wide bylaw
I totally agree look I'll move on to the
next question which is battery disposal
facility now
I just want some feedback on that and
then I'll invite Aaron to provide some
some comment so would there be support
for that around that yeah absolutely
thank you absolutely any other comments
a bit of nodding going on Erin you
wanted to contribute
is I I'm definitely hearing and feeling
the the pressure that um the wag is
putting on stuff around wanting to
progress this issue
um what I would note though is we've got
a number of issues that the wag is
looking to progress and we've got a
workshop program and a budget which
we've approved which provides full
review of the bylaw next calendar year
towards the end of this financial year
to start picking up that piece of work
now unfortunately with the level of
resourcing that we have if the wag would
like to pull that piece of work forward
then it would need to be at the
consequence of pushing another piece of
work out we simply can't pick that piece
up as well at the moment I hear what
you're saying but we've also got the
option given that we have run at a
profit for the last 12 months of of
using some of that money for that
process if need be in bringing in an
extra resources
Ian look
the wmp is critical that our alignment
with it is absolute you look at the
waste minimization act 2008 it says that
all
councils and their actions it must align
with their plan now if we're going to go
ahead
and consult with the glass separation
then that needs to be in our plan
everything that extraction of
the desire to do the green wasteling all
these things need to be in our plant and
our plan at the moment
is neutral on everything as you
mentioned the other day the the forward
by the previous chairperson said we're
in a holding pattern and um
we don't want to be in the holding
pattern we we want to be moving forward
so look I I can't see any piece of work
is more important than the plan
any other comment
so if we can have a report for the next
meeting
um and we can look at timing and the
pros and cons of part of that report so
that we're explicit in our
considerations
and and we'll keep an open mind on the
the timing and funding of it
until discussion at the next meeting
next question it was to do with the
battery disposal facility now
look the batteries are getting to the
point one of these devices here if it's
run over by
a compactor and a landfill will explode
and cause the fire a cell phone
cell phone run over will be an ignition
source for a fire we have to
we have to let the public know that none
of these devices go in the rebounds
um I don't know how we're going to do
that but then there's going to be an
alternative disposal place for them and
the blue cell on page 54 of our agenda
the last bullet pointers a report to the
next week meeting on progress and that's
all that I think you're reinforcing the
need for the report and and for some
short term action okay just to give a
bit of
urgency to it is is if there is a
substantial fire at the landfill caused
by a battery and that fire is not able
to be contained and our landfill is out
of action for a certain period of time
we are in the
and the Deep stuff really because where
does our waist go yeah so yeah
all right any any other comments
feedback on the waste action plan
appears to be none we have a
recommendation the report be received
you know
[Music]
um
no it's consequential to that I think
we'll just deal with receive the report
uh can I have a move of further
recommendation please Ian second Rob
all those in favor say aye
against carried item 9 page 55 the
financial report
do staff have anything further to add to
the report that isn't in it no are there
any questions arising from the report
please Ian
I just want to obviously we've got this
reserved there of 1.8 I just want to
understand moving forward what is our
anticipated income from the levy our
Prime source of income is the levy
on the gate charge at the landfill now
what where is that what is what is our
income so what other sources of income
do we have so on page 56 of the agenda
it just shows the income under contracts
and
um interest and total income
that's managing contracts yes that's
completely different I'm talking about
waste Nets core income which comes from
a separate piece of levy on every ton
that goes to the landfill and also what
what are we doing with
um
the 50 of the government Levy of fifty
dollars the the fifty percent of that we
get back
I mean that's what we can test so you're
wanting to see a more detailed breakdown
yeah I just I mean to me these aren't
financials of our true
um you know
um
it doesn't show our income at all
and that is their income that's how
we've accumulated 1.8 million
from that
but it was then over three years two
years one year I don't know
I've got no idea
so the the 1.8 I guess is accumulated
over about five years or more
but from what yes
so
um Aaron are you able to assist there
or is it something that's going to
require a bit more work
um the revenue that's sitting in race
net is accrued from the admin fee that
we charge over every ton that goes to
the landfill which is 17 point sorry I
can't remember it's roughly around 18
this year and last year it was sitting
at 13 points something so it's been
accrued over a period of time probably
over the period of five years
I just add to that that the intention is
each year to set the admin fee to cover
the operating costs of waste net for the
year we did decide this year to not
cover the full costs as we did have that
reserved so there was a bit of a mix of
both but the normal procedure would be
to set the admin fee at a level to cover
the operating cost
I guess the critical part of that is
that obviously we talked about the
contestable fund for you know waste
minimization ID itself you know it's 50
000. obviously if we knew more about
what our income was going to be and and
if you look at the challenges
um predicted challenges over the years
going there and we only collect
a levy on waste generated from South
London not the Queenstown stuff or
anything like that so it's that we
should have a rough idea and that from
that if we know the cost of running
Wasteland and then we should be able to
work out that fifty thousand dollars or
it could be 150 it could be 25. I think
I just don't see enough well for me I
don't see enough detail
of when you you wouldn't run your
household budget like this
as far as I'm concerned
knowing your income where you know what
it's going to be
right
just sort of I think I mean you're not
going to know what your income is going
to be at the start of the year you're
going to find out what it is at the end
but just reflecting on that Surplus I
mean if it was a business we'd be
celebrating that we've got half a
million dollar Surplus but just I think
factoring in that it's it's rate payers
funding there what
going forwards if we're expecting that
kind of a surplus going on I think you
can't answer the question and saying you
do adjust the admin feeder Corner suit
so I think that that will inherently
smooth it out and I think next year
would potentially see less of a surplus
is that a fair kind of assumption
I think that um we've got a desire that
we're aware of from most councils to
supplement the three bin system out of
some of that backlog
um I think that'll probably pull us back
to a position where we won't have that
significant Surplus and that we'd just
be setting the admin fee each year based
on what we're budgeting to expend that
year
and I guess there's some corollary
issues that arise that we'll consider in
the public excluded Provisions when it
gets into a bit more detail any other
comment
questions
so we have a recommendation that the
um
the final pre-order version the
financial report for the year be
received can I have a mover of that
please rob second uh Barry or those in
favor say aye
against carried
item 10 just refers to our next meeting
which is Monday the 16th of October to
be hosted at the invercargill city
council
so that brings us to the end of the
public
um
portion of of the meeting
I now like to move that the waste net
Advisory Group exclude the public from
the following parts of the proceedings
of this meeting